i i want to ask like because we like
growing up we had the problem of like
our anime was for example on youtube and
sometimes there would be like
an episode or a part of an episode that
wasn't uploaded
what was it like for you where you had
to actually get physical vhs saves were
you just did you have to like watch
anime episodes out of order or like if
some episodes were available you just
get them anyway
i think it was i mean because the thing
about that
is it's much easier to delete things
than you know so that's why like
something would be a copyright or
whatever i don't know whatever
channel would go down yeah but back then
like everybody had like physical media
so it all like exists like it's not
going to disappear as long as you didn't
lose the physical tape
yeah as long as you had it it's like
it's there and you know that someone
else has it like they can just
make a copy and send it to you so
physically yeah and
people would be very it goes back then
people like hardcore
into it so they'd have a complete
collection that wasn't really an issue
no right
if you wanted to see something it was
was it expensive oh man i don't even
know how much i've spent
yeah right because i have people out
here complaining about a six sellers
monthly subscription yeah yeah
if i could pay that six bucks a month
back then for
almost unlimited content wow that's uh
how much stuff how much consumers so how
much did you have to pay for like
a single vhs table or like a like if you
wanted to watch an anime a series
what would that cost okay so the the
best thing was when
uh the australian distributors like
madman and stuff started to make
because you the japanese discs would
have like
two or three episodes yeah yeah it'd be
like sixty dollars
yeah it's like it's it's like that to
this day as well yeah yeah right
i just don't get it whereas oversea
that's the best thing like american
other countries where
they make you know it's like the whole
season or one or one thing it's like
that's how it should be right it's still
good quality and subtitles and
everything so
yeah i mean but i didn't really i didn't
really spend money on anything else i
was just
i didn't
you went from one expensive hobby to
another man
so that makes me curious then how did
you because obviously i've seen in your
videos as well
you can speak japanese like i'm much
better than being gone
like 100 um how did you
were you learning japanese before you
moved to japan and also when did you
move to japan like what made you do that
uh so i so i used to work at a car
magazine in australia
okay so but originally so what i did was
went to university didn't like that
studied three it was just that quick
you're like yeah two lessons in i'm done
well it'd be like that we'll be like a
smoke
i was just like it's like whatever it's
just something i don't know what i want
to do and
so i but i uh in the meantime while i
was doing that i was studying animation
all right like actual like physical with
pieces of paper and i was super hyper
into this sort of stuff yeah so
you know i had my own thing and i was
doing like little test things or
whatever
uh so then i started to learn 3d
animation and this is back when
if you heard the program maya oh yeah
maya this is like my i was learning like
maya 1.5 or something
yeah original it was running on irix
boxes which is a
silicon graphics irix which is like a
unix proprietary unix
and one box would be like twelve
thousand dollars
jesus yeah to learn on so i was i
learned this i learned this 3d software
because i wanted i want to do animation
like that's what i liked
and did that got jobs doing that which
paid really well back then because no
one knew how to do it
yeah it was very you had to be you you
had to know you had to churn out content
real quick and so i was
i was young i was like 23 or four or
something and i just
i go there in the morning work hours and
hours and you know
nothing else to do so i'd always get the
work done got paid really good but let's
say let me go and watch anime
that was good um so then i got kind of
burned out on that
right doing it wasn't what i'd imagined
it was a lot like how long are you doing
that for
uh probably about five six years oh wow
it was i mean it was good um but it's
very high you know
the crunches and things like that yeah
he like they just shovel content
here do all this stuff and you're like
this sucks and just sit there all day
but at the same time i've got my
headphones on listening to japanese
lessons
listening to you know because for some
reason like i think if you're doing
creative work and language it doesn't
mix in your right yeah i could sort of
listen
konnichiwa oh oh mr you know
like again and again and again so just
stuck right right while i'm doing that
so
then got burned out of that came to
japan i wanted to do anime stuff and car
stuff
right how how did you come here like
what was the process like did you get
like a
no i just a tourist oh just tourist okay
originally yeah just as as a tourist
uh i wanted to see car stuff i wanted to
see anime stuff so i went to
you know akihabara i had the it was all
in a notebook
all written out and that no no google
maps none of this
i didn't know what i was looking for so
what year was this this is like 2000
oh oh my gosh yeah it was like not
i was blind yeah yeah every like i had i
had two friends who'd been to japan
one who'd done car stuff one who'd done
he'd sort of gone akihabara yeah yeah so
he's like drawing me
hand-drawn maps of like okay so this is
the last building and if you turn this
way there's the bridge and you walk that
way because that's where all the stuff
is like
okay um because i didn't have any
friends who wanted to do car stuff and
anime stuff
so you've done the same thing i'm sure
you
you burn yourself out you get up in the
morning you go do stuff all day you
don't eat you don't drink you just do
more all this sort of stuff you're going
to the hotel fall asleep wake up just do
it again
so i go out again and went up to abc
circuit by myself
and you went all the way to fukushima by
yourself
no i took the train okay i was blind a
friend of mine who was the
who worked at a magazine actually he's a
friend of a friend he worked at a
magazine and i
just said he sort of knew who i was so i
messaged him like well
i i emailed him said hey can you tell me
how to get the abc circuit he said just
go to nihon matsu station and just get
in the taxi and just say absolute
circuit
are you going there i'm like yeah oh can
you write an article
about the the event right for the
magazine
yeah so i've got my mum's little
panasonic
like digital camera oh 32 megabyte
memory cards
not gigabyte so i go up there i see the
event just blows my mind yeah
cool stuff is a big competition uh which
i i now do the commentary for which is
kind of cool
yeah yeah go back
i write this article and then i was like
oh it was really good and then a few
weeks you know about a month later
you want a job yes i'm sick of doing 3d
i hate it
so i started working the magazine and
every chance i'd
i could i come to japan and this is how
we did it this is how these
people have to remember this sort of
stuff you somehow make money
when you come here right if you can like
people do that by
making youtube videos and stuff like
that yeah yeah yeah what i did was i
would come here go do car stuff
i'd take photos of it write articles go
back and i get paid for going on holiday
right so it's a double win yeah it's
like this is this is perfect
i have gained the system right so okay
i've got this figured out and it got to
the point where
literally everyone i knew was like lexi
just shut the [ __ ] up and go live there
that's all you talk about oh like my car
friends everyone's like alexis
japanese japan well in japan well in
japan they do this and japan do that so
just go i said okay fine i will
so working holiday visa right 18 months
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna quit everything sell
everything i'm gonna live there for a
year and a half if it works out if
i've had a good holiday i can i can just
shut up about and get out of my system
yeah
we'll see what happens yeah so came here
and
just did the same thing just you know
went around shooting articles
writing things selling them to magazines
selling them to all around the world in
english
and it just sort of built up from there
so like you know taking photos
oh look at these cool random photos i've
taken of this cool stuff i'll make a
a wordpress wordpress blog which is what
everybody did back then yeah this is
like 2008.
yeah yeah yeah okay wordpress blog then
at the same time so that became a
popular thing
then you know i oh this is really cool
i've got this little
sony vloggy you know camera it only
shows i think i have the exact same
camera
yeah it's like oh let's just shoot this
car doing something cool because
it looks you know it's moving it's
making noise here we go
let's do that that's what makes them
cool was it the old like
sony handycams it was original it was a
tiny little one oh
okay so so shoot all that and then that
goes on youtube
well that becomes more popular uh you
know magazines aren't popular they don't
make any money anymore they don't want
to pay
eight hundred thousand dollars for a big
article these days
okay youtube pays money let's do youtube
and it's just sort of snowballed from
there